White House press secretary Kelly
mcenany isn't pulling any punches with
the mob and the media take a look
finally I didn't with this you know I
was asked probably 12 questions about
the Confederate flag this president
focused on action and I'm a little
dismayed that I didn't receive one
question on the deaths that we got it in
this country this weekend what else
press secretary Kelly mcenany joins us
you know it's such a good point we have
hundreds of people shot every weekend if
anyone wants to have a debate about
memorials or statues I'm all I'm open
for debate anybody
can we do it while were simultaneously
protecting the life of every American
citizen in every city in town in the
country because our kids are now dying
at six seven and eight from bullets in
their head yeah Sean that's exactly
right I actually went back and counted
on my way here I was asked more than
twenty four questions about the
Confederate flag not one about these
children and good on you to show the
pictures of these kids we need to know
their faces know their name so Coria
turner who lost her life in atlanta this
is a tragedy this is happening on
America's streets because of Democrat
mayors and Democrat governors and
there's fundamental on interest in
getting to the bottom of it by many in
the press it's despicable and it just
goes to show how out of touch people are
here in the swamp and the president I
think it was a great idea Garden of
Heroes honoring everybody all races
backgrounds code that that are great
Americans so you have combined over 125
years experience if we were stupid
enough as a country to elect Biden
Pelosi and Schumer well they didn't do
Opportunity Zones they didn't do
criminal justice reform they didn't do
police reform historically black
colleges and they didn't shatter record
after record low unemployment for
minorities in America and they had eight
years to do it why didn't they do it
words of one thing symbolisms one thing
actions and success or another that's
exactly right and while you listed off
president Trump did with action making
permanent HBCU funding criminal justice
reform Louis black unemployment rate in
history but what do Democrats have to
offer us failed experiments like chop
where two children died in a
miss zone failed cities like Chicago
where you saw 13 killed last weekend 77
injured like New York City where you've
had for three weeks a many fold increase
in shootings this is what leftist
policies have gotten us in the black
community in particular poverty crime in
the cities and it's taken president
Trump to rescue people from that
scenario and give hope an opportunity I
noticed the mob is criticizing you New
York Times and others and I'm thinking
well that means you're doing a great job
does it bother you at all I take it as a
badge of honor Shawn if they're
criticizing me guess what that means I'm
getting to them I'm pushing their
buttons I'm not gonna play their game
that they like to play with any
Republican who comes to this town I'm
speaking the truth that's what I intend
to do and the truth is that this
president has done so much for this
country they don't give them an ounce of
credit but we will give him credit from
the White House podium all right you
know what Caylee great job I don't know
many people in America are cheering your
beatdowns daily and they deserve it and
more thank you for being with us